on essaie avec avec le salon justement
de proposer les torts de réponses aux
questions que se posent les personnes en
situation d'handicap qui aujourd'hui
effectivement donc ont beaucoup de
difficultés à avoir une activité
professionnelle et à avoir à trouver la
confiance au sein de des entreprises
pour pouvoir intégrer le poste quel
qu'il soit le salon s'adresse vraiment à
toute personne à tout le monde valide
comme vous on cherche un handicap
et quand on parle de personnages
cherchent un handicap on parle également
des personnes qui subissent un handicap
au cours de leur vie et surtout point
les handicaps qui seraient
éventuellement invisible donc même si
votre handicap ne se voit pas vous êtes
aussi concernés et nous sommes aussi là
vous accompagner